m
[Musique]
mon marque n'est pas la place du tertre
toute une population continue d'y vivre
plutôt heureuse
[Musique]
la vie est cependant devenu trop cher
dans ce quartier de paris où vivent
beaucoup de gens âgés parmi eux certains
on tue à s'organiser et à se battre pour
ne pas être expulsées de leur logement
[Musique]
monsieur froyo cette maison a failli et
des mots lui la fa lui est démolie ya
cinq ans et c'est une des raisons pour
laquelle nous avons fondé cette
association de montmartre du la défense
de montmartre 18e alors la maison était
condamnée mais évidemment tout
l'environnement ici qui est le dernier
vestige du maquis de montmartre depuis
la percée de l'avenue junot en 1909
était sur les mesures urgentes alors que
évidemment l'association ne s'est pas
arrêté à ce point on est toujours dans
l'inquiétude c'est jamais fini car ce
parking de denat faîtage est toujours en
suspens donc il faut toujours être
alertées mais depuis nous avons eu des
tas de problèmes sur la butte
d'autres parkings du reste dans le
square ville est en dessous le sacré
coeur
et puis alors d'autres choses comme les
soeurs du cénacle où aussi veut y avoir
une démolir tout pour refaire encore des
maisons de standing comme il y en a déjà
au moulin de la galette ce qui
transforme tout un quartier point de vue
sa population au sort du sénat
c'est un espace vert qui est encore plus
grand que celui du moulin de la galette
et nous espérons nous sommes en bonne
voie de le sauver grâce à toute la
population qui nous a rejoints ne
trouvez-vous pas que notre quartier de
plus en plus sales sales oui mais ça il
ya aussi il faut bien vous dire qu'on a
un quartier qui est absolument pollué
par le tourisme on ne peut pas le
refuser il est là mais il faut tout même
s'arranger et nous voudrions justement
dans l'association canaliser un peu cet
envahissement et puis surtout protéger
un peu les gens de
montmartre de façon à ce qu'ils puissent
garder leur identité au milieu de tout
ce monde
ce ne sont pas les touristes qui sont
responsables de l'état d'abandon du
square des cds claude charpentier nous
rassure pour l'avenir dans deux ans vous
aurez un score remarquable
le projet est intéressant vous savez
qu'on va relier la rue des trois frères
maintenant à la place des abbesses
il y aura plusieurs étages dans ce soir
puisqu'il y a les anciennes fondations
d' abbey qui se trouve dans le fond du
soir sur lequel il y aura un premier
étage et puis vous aurez sept petits
cheminement qui s'en ira vers la rue des
trois frères
je pense que cette installation sera
très intéressante et enfin remise en
état car actuellement c'est évidemment
dans un état déplorable dans ses beaux
jardins privés privé d'enfants
s'abolissent la rumeur et la misère les
quartiers de l'exil pourtant proche
ici aussi les arbres valent de l'or
dans cette cité des fusains ou pas c'est
renoir de rares bonnart bientôt les
artistes ne pourront plus acquérir
d'ateliers
georges joubin vie et pas ici depuis
plus de 50 ans
[Musique]
oui